انتم ختنا احنا ليبيين كنا زي بعض خلال
الحرب الليبيه عام 2011 دعت ايمان العبيدي
بانها اغتصبت على يد مجموعه من عناصر
الكتائب الامنيه المواليه للزعيم الليبي
الراحل معمر القذافي وفي مجتمع يعتبر
جرائم الجنس امرا محظورا كسرت ايمان حاجز
الصمت وتكلمت بما لا يجرؤ مجتمعها بنطقه
تكلمت عن عمليه اغتصابها التي صورت بهواتف
تمت مصادرتها من موالين للقذافي انذاك من
المعلومات المؤكده ذا ان هذا الاغتصاب تم
بشكل ممنهج لكن هذه الاعمال الوحشيه لم
تبدا ولن تشهد نهايتها في ليبيا فاحصي
الامم المتحده تفيد بان ما بين 20 الى 50
الف امراه اغتصبت خلال الحرب البوسنيه
وتتزايد الارقام في حرب سيراليون حيث وصلت
حصيله ضحايا الاغتصاب الى 65 الف ضحيه اما
في مجزره رواندا فان اكثر من 500 الف
امراه تم اغتصابهن خلال النزاع الذي استمر
100 يوم وفي جمهوريه الكونجو الديم قراطيه
قامت مراكز الصحه بالابلاغ عن 40 حاله
اغتصاب كل يوم وقعت في مناطق النزاع حينها
ولكن هنا تقل العداله مع ازدياده عدد
الاشخاص المختبئين خلف جدار
الصمت نحن هنا لنطالب بامر بسيط للغايه
فنحن نطالب الحكومه في الخرطوم بايقاف
قتلها لمواطنيها من رجال ونساء واطفال
عليهم ان يتوقفوا عن اغتصابهم
وتجويعهم نحن نعلم ما هي مطالب ضحايا هذه
الجريمه تحقيق العداله والاعتراف بهذه
الماساه هذا وقد قامت سفيره النوايا
الحسنه للامم المتحده انجلينا جولي بانشاء
مبادره بالتعاون مع الحكومه البريطانيه
لمعاقبه من يقومون بارتكاب مثل هذه
الجرائم وللمحامي على ما اصبح يعرف منذ
عام 2001 بجرائم ضد
الانسانيه